[Musik]
eine moderatorin die man hören aber kaum
noch sehen kann das ist jetzt gesetz in
afghanistan
nach anfänglichen protesten beugten sich
die medienfrauen schließlich den druck
von oben
das arbeiten für frauen in afghanistan
ist schwer geworden seitdem die taliban
an der macht sind
denn die regierung des islamischen
emirats hat sich gegen uns frauen
verschworen
die bevölkerung hätte sich angesichts
der zwanghaften gender apartheid in
galgenhumor so der afghanische autor und
afghanistan-experte am rand firus
innerhalb von afghanistan macht man sich
auch mittlerweile über die taliban
darüber lustig dass sie sonst nichts auf
die reihe bringen würden aber
anscheinend den frauen den krieg erklärt
haben die ganze zeit so
krankhaft
fixiert sind auf frauen und sie wirklich
in jederlei hinsicht kontrollieren
wollen
die frauen kontrollieren nicht nur vor
laufender kamera auch im öffentlichen
leben ist jetzt offiziell die
vollverschleierung gesetz bei
zuwiderhandlung wird nicht die frau
bestraft sondern ihr männlicher vormund
ein weiteres indiz für die vollkommene
entmündigung der frau
die ärztin sima samar war die erste
frauenministerin in afghanistan und
vize-präsidentin für sie markiert die
machtergreifung der taliban das ende
ihrer zahlreichen frauen projekte die
sie in den vergangenen 20 jahren ins
leben gerufen hat der neue erlass spalte
die familien sagt sie
mit dem gesetz der vollverschleierung
wird die gewalt in die familien
einziehen
denn der männliche form und wird darauf
aufpassen dass die frau das haus nicht
verlässt denn er ist es der bestraft
wird falls sie ihr gesicht in der
öffentlichkeit nicht verdeckt
wieso das überhaupt gehen eine lehrerin
oder ärztin soll unter einer brücke
arbeiten das ist nicht praktikabel
eine journalistin die die nachrichten
und einer burka liest als nächstes kommt
dass auch die stimme nicht mehr gehört
werden darf
[Musik]
die stimme der journalistin maria ist
noch zu hören aufgeben für sie keine
option
sie stellt unerschrocken männer aus der
führungsriege zur rede debattenkultur
auf hohem niveau die in afghanistan in
den vergangenen 20 jahren weiter
verfeinert wurde
marianna juli in einem interview mit
einem ranghohen taliban sie allein im
bild warum sein islamisches emirat nicht
auf die forderungen der westlichen welt
eingehe den frauen mehr rechte zu
gewähren so ihre frage international
seien die taliban ja deshalb immer noch
nicht anerkannt
der taliban sprecher sabiullah
mudschahid etwas formelhaft dass kein
land das recht habe sich in die
angelegenheiten eines anderen landes
einzumischen und bedingungen zu stellen
das sei ohnehin alles nur vorwand um uns
nicht anzuerkennen
die hardliner unter den taliban aus den
1990 er jahren sind wieder an der macht
radikale islamisten die zum engsten
kreis des inzwischen verstorbenen
taliban gründers mullah omar zählten
auch neun monate nach ihrer
machtergreifung die taliban immer noch
in der pose der guerillakrieg und die
bilanz dramatisch mehr als die hälfte
der bevölkerung leidet hunger nur über
internationale note hilfsprogramme
konnte eine schwere hungersnot
abgewendet werden statt zu regieren
werden ideologisch religiöse fragen
diskutiert vor allem im westen aber auch
unter säkularen menschen im allgemeinen
herrscht generell eine gewisse
unkenntnis wenn es um so ein
demokratisches regime geht die taliban
selbst haben eine total andere
weltanschauung sie denken gar nicht zum
teil an die internationale
staatengemeinschaft sondern sagen dann
sachen wie gott wird unser problem lösen
wir sind muslime und wir müssen beten
und auch der hunger und alle andere all
die anderen sorgen werden durch die
gebete gelöst und nicht durch
irgendwelche
internationalen geldgeber sei es aus den
usa oder anderswo
hoffnung dass sich die lage in
afghanistan in absehbarer zeit ändert
gibt es wenig die taliban sind bis an
die zähne bewaffnet haben das absolute
macht monopole anders als in den 1990 er
jahren kontrollieren sie inzwischen das
ganze land auch ehemalige abtrünnige
provinzen angst vor gewalt und
anschlägen bestimmt den alltag
die afghanische gesellschaft hat in den
letzten 44 jahren so gelitten dass sie
denken solange man mich nicht schlägt
oder tötet reicht das schon
ich habe noch nie eine solche stehe im
land wahrgenommen wie dieses mal
afghanistan ist für journalistinnen
eines der gefährlichsten länder der welt
frau und reporterin ist man doppelt
gefährdet doch maria alibi wird nicht
verstummen
für mich kommt es nicht in frage nach
europa auszuwandern oder in irgendein
anderes land ich lebe hier ich arbeite
hier ich kämpfe hier
leben oder tod das ist schicksal
sie wird weiter kämpfen für die zukunft
der mädchen und frauen ihres landes und
dafür dass der traum von sichtbarkeit
und selbstbehauptung irgendwann einmal
in erfüllung geht
[Musik]